do you know that spider-man is actually
an avid reader of DC Comics weird right
yeah he talks about a lot only he'd
actually talk about being an Avenger ah
well we can all dream right oh wait
Marvel and Sony are working together now
they're building a new one without all
the bad decisions of the previous two
incarnations we have the guy behind the
awesome daredevil series giving ideas on
it it'll have ties to the MCU and a
brand new cast this one won't do the
origin story all over again and it will
start off with an established finalized
spider-man think about it all the other
movies are like drawn-out origin stories
the only time he's fully realized in his
role was in spider-man 3 and we all know
how that turned out look now we get
another shot to do it right is this
great news yes then why is everyone so
mad about it it's finally happening all
the pieces are set third time's a charm
we have yet another spider-man reboot
within a 10 year span or perhaps things
will finally work out now I understand
it from the point of view of someone
casual watching these movies and
thinking they're making a new spider-man
again but to someone who is very
unforgiving towards amazing spider-man 2
or simply someone who's incredibly
invested into comics this is all great
news but everyone's mad there's a ton of
nerd rage controversy over who should
play the new spider-man before we look
to the future let's take a step back and
talk about the sins of the past shall we
now regarding the casting I have some
unpopular opinions about our previous to
Parker's I didn't like Andrew Garfield
or Tobey Maguire both had strong points
but neither truly gave a good portrayal
of Peter Parker Peter Parker is a very
two-sided character and both actors
could only give one half of the equation
tobey's strong suit was that he was
great as an uncharismatic nerd with
social anxiety in a laundry list of
problems in life as long as your arm he
talked to himself because he had only
one friend that he rarely saw I am Jay
hey MJ I don't know if you realize this
but we've we've been neighbors since I
was six and I was wondering if maybe
we can get together sometime do
something fun
or I don't know how'd it be time to get
to know each other
ha
you got pushed around by a brony knew
and he just couldn't talk to the pretty
girl at school this is great stuff to
get you emotionally especially if you're
pathetic nerd who spends all their time
reading comics and not getting laid
maybe that's why this character was so
popular at the start he was just a
duplicate of his readers Toby nailed
that sadness and nerdy little charm as
Peter Parker but he was missing a
crucial element he couldn't play
spider-man now this is the big thing
Peter Parker and spider-man are
essentially two different people and
when he puts the mask on he just can't
measure up
sure you could blame it on the writing
but the quota of one joke per movie made
him pretty boring in costume you hardly
ever hear him even talking the
personality is just completely sucked
away with the costume change Peter
Parker is tragic and relatable
spider-man is the badass we all want to
be spider-man cracks jokes about the
other guys costume or pokes fun at
someone's name or nonsensical actions
this is my profession
you do this for a living with that
accent I was thinking rodeo clowns don't
you mock me boy I mock I'm a mocker I
feel like this was just a drawback of
the writing exclusively because in the
PlayStation 2 spider-man games he did
the voice and he was perfect so you must
be quilt man patted Pete mr. triple-ply
oh I've got it the cushion I'm the
Shocker this may not be art but I like
it
shouldn't you be helping some old lady
across the street or something man
I already got that merit badge but by
the nature of the medium he couldn't be
the tragic nerd he had to be spider-man
because it's a video game and that he
did it was all there he made jokes he
kicked ass and he was a blast to follow
and even aspire to being his performance
was cut in two halves and neither make a
full picture
it's sad that he never got to do both
now in Andrew Garfield's case he was as
wrong as you can get the Peter Parker he
is the exact opposite of what we needed
Garfield was confident
brave good with girls and kind of an
idiot sure he dabbled in science as a
plot device but he came off as a
numskull jock who clumsily wandered into
a room full of dangerous science
experiments this was not brush with fate
this was just him casually walking into
God knows what to look at the pretty
lights he learned about his power 30
minutes later by spider manning a bunch
of innocent people into submission
some genius there's this massive
disconnect between his personality and
his ability to be inventive and creative
it just feels like two different people
it doesn't match up Garfield acts
nothing like the person capable of
making these things or coming up with
this stuff even gets the idea to put his
costume together by eavesdropping on two
geeks who are smart enough to do the
science for him that's a common theme
here he isn't smart enough so he lets
other people be nerds in his place to
win
Gwen made the cure to save the city from
being stuck as lizard people Gwen came
up with a way to preserve his
web-shooters during a fight with electro
[ __ ] Glenn should be the superhero she
is the one who gets work done he's just
good at jumping and hitting people and
when his suit is off
he hasn't takes [ __ ] from bullies he
slams the future kind-hearted war hero
Flash Thompson into a locker for trying
to console him for a surrogate father's
death just better right uncle died it's
okay Eugene I believe in you
now I may seem a bit hostile here but I
have something nice to say he seems
great as spider-man all the negatives I
have to say about his acting flip when
he puts the costume on spider-man is the
antithesis of Peter Parker he is
confident brave good with girls and kind
of an idiot spider-man is the version of
Peter Parker that he wishes he could be
all the time part of the difference is
that he gets to be someone else with a
mask on
he plays pretend and acts like a total
badass because in the suit he is without
it you just misunderstood sad-sack Peter
Parker but the inner workings of that
fun and wacky exterior is still lost in
both actors performance Spiderman acted
like a dumb brute but he was still Peter
Parker inside and by extension a genius
internally the bravado was a common
trick to throw off that inside he was
thinking up a way to dismantle the
Doomsday Device or uses knowledge of
physics to get out of a crazy situation
or simply put together a strategy for
kicking the bad guy where it hurts he
isn't like Batman where he knows
everything and gets the point sheet by
using the excusive I had some time to
formulate a plan first Peter Parker
could do all this because he read a book
once in a while Toby wasn't a science
nerd like that and Andrew wasn't a nerd
at all
he was a hipster skateboarder both
failed at the part and I think it's
because the writing wasn't that deep or
because the difficulty of the character
spider-man is a Shakespearean character
with layers of complexity
he's like Citizen Kane and tights I want
to look for and see someone new play the
role and work with the duality of his
spirit and childlike sense of wonder he
feels in the red and blue onesie Peter
you lead such a sheltered life speaking
of what's wrong with casting someone
young for the part why can't a 15 or 16
year old actor play spider-man who is a
15 or 16 year old I have a few theories
as to why people are so apprehensive one
people don't know what teenagers look
like because they don't know any real
ones think about this all teenage
characters are played by someone
considerably older probably because
teenage actors suck or grow out of the
role too quickly it's easier to cast a
full-grown adult who looks young ish to
play a 14 year old if the role requires
them to look the same for a few years
like that kid in Breaking Bad was
supposed to be 16 and 17 through the
course of all five seasons of the show
as a 16 a 17 year old I personally know
that is not what we look like you people
have been subtly brainwashed into
thinking that this is what a 14 year old
looks like Walter jr. should be like
half the size of all the adult
characters and have a face shaped like a
basketball and not a cinderblock damn he
is handsome or to everyone's proposed
casting suggestions are awful and wrong
and based on zero knowledge of the
character Logan Lerman Dylan O'Brien or
Josh Hutcherson sake are you people
that's stupid these casting suggestions
are made by people who only know about
the Andrew Garfield version where he is
a flawless teen girl dreamboat with a
perfect smile and a rockin bod and
Twilight hair if tons of girls swoon
over how handsome he is then you cast
the wrong person as Peter Parker he's a
bullying victim who girls overlook
because he has good grades and no sports
skills not a handsome tan hipster
heartthrob from a TV show like Teen Wolf
I will submit to you that anyone who
wants dylan o'brien logan lerman and
josh hutcherson or anyone like that is a
stupid teenage girl who doesn't know
what she's talking about
or an idiot who has never read a comic
book I am not budging on this Grant
Gustin is not believable as a forensic
scientist there I said it
so in short people are dumb and don't
know what a realistic teenager looks
like that's why they're complaining that
any of the proposed actors for marvel
look too young that's what it 16 year
old looks like and people are dumb for
thinking they know who else should be
good for the part because they base it
on who gets them the most tingly in the
nether regions
that's not right Marvel wants to stay
true to the nature of the character and
it's time for a new view both previous
versions came up short somehow and maybe
a new perspective can come from someone
younger and simpler I'm open to the idea
because we haven't seen it before
press interviews with Kevin fig fig
Feige fish suggests that he gets the
duality of the character he said himself
that he doesn't fit in and with the
costume on he becomes a motormouth
Marvel has been great at casting in the
past I'm hard-pressed to think of one
actor who is aggressively bad at their
part sure some of the villains have been
lame but the heroes have been great so
far people need to stop acting like they
know who absolutely needs to be the next
incarnation they need to stop shutting
down any of Marvel's suggestions without
hesitation at the moment the
front-runner for the role is the kid
from Hugo and Ender's Game you haven't
seen a sub Butterfield on screen as
Spidey yet based on his previous work
the only worry is that he can't do
comedy that well he looks great for the
part he is a good actor as far as we
know and he's taller than the other two
guys you know that whoever made that
meme didn't know how to do basic
research he's not inherently flawed for
the part like some of the other
suggestions and I'm sure he could do a
whole lot better with the script so
everyone pull your heads from your
pumpkin moms and start thinking with a
clearer mind stop being such an ass
Goblin you mean like selling pictures to
the bugle instead of helping your
friends look straight up I blew it and I
know you're ticked don't go all emo on
me bro no no of course not
you